des buts des gestes et techniques ce
dimanche au 8 juillet monti le
bretonneux après des allures de coupe du
monde ou plutôt de coupe d'europe avec
sept équipes féminines venues de france
d'angleterre et d'allemagne tournoi créé
il ya deux ans regroupe les villes
jumelées à montigny le bretonneux ses
rangs créer un lien un lien aller entre
les différentes villes de jumelage de
mon team moto2 c'est aussi de créer des
liens entre les filles puisque jeudi la
dernière on étale à benton ya eu des les
fils sont et des messages et reste en
contact
c'est s'est développée aussi c'est
mettre en avant le que le foot c'est
aussi ça peut être libérateur ce jour-là
70 joueuses de moins de 16 ans se sont
affrontés sur des matches à 7 contre 7
mais l'essentiel est ailleurs pour ses
footballeuses c'est bien enfin ça change
des équipes du 78 après ouais c'est
mieux d'autres langues de tête
c'est ce convivial voilà on partage tous
la même passion le football à travers
deux pays du coup ça nous permet aussi
de voir comment il joue dans les pays
bas fing et skoda je pense que c'est
bien ça permet aux gens de se retrouver
de pouvoir interagir
nous apprenons des nouvelles langues on
peut parler avec des français des
allemands et apprendre à se connaître
catherine rich l'année prochaine le
tournoi pourrait connaître une nouvelle
édition mais cette fois ci en allemagne